- Good afternoon, everyone.
I am Kristina Talbert-Slagle,
assistant professor of
general internal medicine,
and associate director
at the Yale Institute
for Global Health and the
Yale School of Medicine.
I am delighted to welcome you
to the Yale Institute for Global
Health conversation series
a venue for our community
to learn from and connect
with innovative leaders in global health.
Coming from diverse backgrounds,
our invited guests will introduce us
to cutting edge work and global health,
including research,
implementation, policy,
and many other perspectives.
In addition to the Yale
Institute of global health
we are indebted to the George
Herbert Walker Jr. lecture
and international studies
at the Whitney and Betty MacMillan Center
for International and Area Studies at Yale
for co-sponsoring this series,
including today's event.
Today, I am pleased to be joined
by my co-moderator Dr. Onyema Ogbuagu,
associate professor of
medicine and director
of HIV clinical trials at
the Yale School of Medicine.
Welcome Onyema, it is great
to have you with us today.
- Thank you, Kristina.
- And now, let me introduce
today's distinguished guest,
Dr. Bernice Dahn, the former
minister of health in Liberia
and current vice president
for health sciences
at the University of Liberia.
Dr. Dahn is renowned for her work,
rebuilding Liberia
postwar healthcare system.
The second Liberian civil
war from 1999 to 2003
decimated Liberia's health infrastructure
and compelled many of its
health workers to flee.
As deputy minister for health services
and chief medical officer,
Dr. Dahn was integral
in bringing into Liberia's
2015 Ebola outbreak.
She developed treatment and
infection prevention protocols
organized training, mobilized resources
and restored routine
health service delivery.
Critical steps that likely
saved thousands of lives,
after Ebola as minister
of health, Dr. Dahn
created a seven year initiative
to improve and expand the
public health workforce.
And she developed with partners,
Liberia's first national
cancer control strategy,
in her current role as vice
president for health sciences
at the University of Liberia,
Dr. Dahn spearheaded, the
critical revitalization
of medical nursing and midwifery schools,
creating a new educational
and training pathway
for healthcare professionals
in the country.
Welcome Dr. Dahn, it is an
honor to have you with us today.
- Thank you, Kristina.
And good afternoon to everybody.
It is good to connect once
more with the US community,
and everybody who is on
this in this session.
I hope that we are being able to cope well
with COVID and we can
move our lives forward.
We'll also like to congratulate Onyema
who is working seriously to support some
of the COVID prevention activities
the vaccine, production, trials
and we are looking forward
to results from there
so it can put us at ease again.
Welcome to everybody and I am here
to listen and answer your
questions, thank you.
- Thank you so much, Dr. Dahn.
So Onyema and I, have
prepared a few questions.
We also welcome questions
from the audience,
please put them through the chat
and we will look forward to
sharing them with Dr. Dahn,
as we go along in this conversation.
So Dr. Dahn, let me
just start by asking you
can you speak to how you
approach to the concept
of systems rebuilding in
a post-crisis setting?
Was that response different
for different types of crises
such as a pandemic versus a civil war,
and how did you achieve political
buy-in for the response?
- Okay, thank you Kristina.
Liberia's healthcare system
have been repeatedly challenged by crisis.
So from the civil war, the Ebola,
post Ebola and now COVID.
Rebuilding for Liberia
has been in to folds,
from the crisis and then the setbacks
that was caused by the Ebola outbreak.
In any of those situations,
strong government leadership
is very important.
There's a need for a well defined
and well articulated vision.
The vision can not be in your
head for the entire country,
so it has to be documented
and it has to be accessible
to everybody, including the locals
those who it will benefit all
the different stakeholders
including those who support
you to implement them.
Now, in the Liberia context,
and I've seen this globally also,
when there's a change from
one government administration
to another, it just a perfect
opportunity to articulate
visions and position,
especially if you are working
in this sector up to
position the sectors vision,
because at that time, the government
and all its partners, and well wishers
who will support the government to grow,
looking up to the
government for leadership
for them to make decisions.
For example,
normally the government will be defining
their 90 days deliverables,
150 days deliverables.
And that is a perfect
opportunity to articulate
to use that timing to position the sector.
So the Liberia health sector at the time
took advantage of that and
at the time coming from war,
the human resources were not there,
but we also had partners
who were on the ground
who were also supporting the government
during the emergency and was
looking up to the government
during the rebuilding process
on roles that they could play.
So we leveraged that partnership
using both resources, human and financial
to develop our first
national policy and strategy.
So the policy and
strategy was co-designed,
with the governments in the leadership,
the government, it is
important to emphasize
that the government has to provide
true leadership for ownership.
And so with that, for us
it helped to build confidence
between us and the partners,
but more importantly,
because the policy and those
instruments were co-designed,
the partners also positioned themselves
as to how they can help the
government to deliver things
that we all agreed on in there.
Remember, Liberia is a
resource limited country,
the entire government budget is less
than 600 million up to today's date.
The ministry of health or
the health sector budget
for most time range, between
12 to 14% of the total budget,
about 70 to 80% of that budget
pays health workers salary.
And so that was like, not much left
to even start building the systems
that you are there to build.
So there was a need to work
and leverage partnerships
both local and international to be able
to deliver the strategy and the plan.
So that means we develop a framework
within which who are going to work.
The Ministry of Health also developed
some financial planning
tools for the health sector.
So, in developing those tools
remember that we're coming from war,
most of our professionals
have left the country,
there were very few persons in
country who knew what to do.
So again, we co-designed those tools,
the financial planning tools.
So their plan itself was costed,
costing the plan helped to
build additional confidence.
Partners knew, and even
the government knew
at least how much it was going
to take to deliver the plan.
And so that helped for people
to mobilize the resources
and plan to support its implementation.
The tools also helped
to map donor support.
So we were able to map who
the donors were in country,
where they were supporting
and what they were supporting.
And from the initial stages you could see
clearly there were overlaps, duplications
and at that time they were supporting the
implementing partners directly.
So with the resource mapping tool,
we engaged the donors.
We were at first and I remember
we designed the plans together.
So we were friends and we had
to come back together to ensure
that what we all put in the
plan, we were supporting that.
So we used the resource mapping tool
to do geographic redistribution
of the resources.
So we negotiated with the donors,
to support where we
think we had serious gaps
and we need their help.
And so that was done,
and that helped to bridge
some of the equity gap also.
Now that system was moving on well,
I believe we all know that,
Liberia was able to achieve
the under five mortality
reduction, the MDGs
within three years before the end date.
Even though we started at six years late,
then we had the Ebola outbreak.
The Ebola outbreak, the scale
of the outbreak took over.
Before the outbreak, in the initial plan
we had a unit designed,
so respond to emergencies
and so whenever there
was like Measles outbreak
Yellow Fever, we sent a team
to the county to support them.
With the outbreak of Ebola because we had,
we were all working together.
We had a coordination
forum that met quarterly,
and another technical working forum
that met monthly.
We called the donors back
and together we redesigned
the emergency system.
So the IMS the incident
management system was established,
emergency operations
centers were established
in the counties and they were supported
with the things that they needed.
The surveillance system was
established, also to respond
these systems that were
developed in response,
so the crisis transition to
more permanent institutions
or procedures with increasing stability.
And so the systems we established
during the Ebola outbreak
we transitioned it to the
national public health institutes
with all its appendices, still functioning
and it functioned, so it
had the main responsibility
off identifying diseases
that had epidemic potential
and responding to them.
And so you are realize
that during the outbreak,
we had to reactivate the
routine healthcare services.
And then we had the emergency system,
the two co-existed at some point
and that's the system that is working now.
So with COVID the outbreak of COVID,
it was very easy to
reactivate the emergency,
the IMS, reacting with
the EOC in the 15 counties
the surveillance team was
also already functioning
so it was a matter of
increasing surge capacity.
With the COVID, the team already knew
it is a disease of epidemic potential.
And looking at our situation,
it wasn't necessarily to isolate
and treat isolate people
who were infected.
All, everybody who was
infected was isolated
and treated in the treatment unit,
everybody who was a contact was isolated
and monitored for the 14 days or so
before they were discharged.
So building a system, the
approach was not too different,
the strategies, policy,
even in the emergency
we developed plans and strategies.
We aligned the partners and
all those things we done,
the implementation to those.
So we use the partners based
on your comparative advantage,
so if you are a donor,
you support the donor
co-ordination and things
that we needed to implement.
If you are an implementing partner,
you supported a county health team
where you were with the
emergency operations center
and all the way down
to the community level.
- Thank you, Dr. Dahn.
again, always nice to talk with you.
So, I want to follow up on that question.
So, we do know that while
rebuilding health systems
it's really important to
consider human capital.
And we know Liberia has significant
healthcare workforce shortages.
You know, you've had
the inglorious position
of having some of the lowest ratios,
of healthcare workers to
population in the world due to,
and also exacerbated by some
of the crises you mentioned earlier
the civil war and the Ebola outbreak.
So, my question to you
is how do you address
rebuilding the healthcare workforce and,
having known of some of your
work we'd love to hear also
about the medical and health sciences
educational programs that you've initiated
to address the pipeline
for healthcare workers.
- Okay, thank you.
The vision to develop fit
for purpose health workforce
was articulated well
in our investment plan
for building a resilient
healthcare delivery system
after the Ebola outbreak.
So that was a part of the
overall national vision
from the beginning.
So during the outbreak, we, first of all
remember that we were coming from crisis.
We had, they had the health workforce
and then health workers died
during the outbreak also.
So, there was a need to actually look
at how we build a workforce
and normally we do these things
everything is on the
line by an assessment.
So it's informed by data,
so we first did an assessment.
The assessment informed
us on the health workers
that we had in acute shortages.
And those that health workforce
that we needed to improve quality.
So if you take the physicians
and the midwives, for example
they findings was for
us to improve quality,
expand the skill mix,
and increase the numbers,
as compared to the nursing
where the finding was
and the recommendation was for us
to improve the quality of training
and increase their skill mix.
So, with this strategy,
with the assessment,
we decided to develop the strategy.
And this time around,
we came across a strategy
that was similar strategy
for Rwanda that partner in
country Rwanda to develop.
So we engaged that partner
and that is (mumbles)
to see how they could help the
Ministry of Health to design.
They help to bring all the other partners
on the table to design the
health workforce strategy.
So that went through a similar process
like the national policy and plan.
So we engaged all the
stakeholders around the table,
we presented the assessment reports
and we used the report to develop
what we call the health
workforce strategy.
Now, with that strategy, the
strategy was also costed,
and so we engaged the partners
to support the strategy,
they were on the table to develop it.
So a good, they had already
positioned themselves
on how they were going to support it.
So USAID for instance decided
to support the mid-level trainings
that we had in the strategy documents.
So the support that supporter
and some other UN US-based NGOs
to work with those training institutions,
midwifery, nursing to really
look at the curriculum
to look at the training resources,
the faculty, and the
systems that will help
to build the educations systems
for the health workforce.
So they have did that
for the mid-level cutter,
then we engaged the World Bank.
At the time, we were seeing
the decline of the Ebola cases
and we had the Ebola
resources from the bank.
And so we engaged the
World Bank to reprogram
to support the health workforce strategy.
And because they had a strategy,
which was the instrument
that defined the government priorities,
they agreed they were going
to support the medical education.
Now the medical education in
that strategy was in two-folds
the undergraduate program,
which did not shut down during the war,
but the quality was
compromised significantly.
And at that time it was graduating
like 200 persons per year,
and we needed to scale up the numbers.
Then we did not have the faculty to teach,
the few physicians who were in country
were the ones doing the teaching
and doing the clinical work.
And so that also helped to compromise
the quality of the training even further.
And so we decided, and then we had a,
we didn't have their
residency training at all.
So at that time, the assessment report
I don't think we even had
10 specialists in country
for any of the specialties.
Even if you put all these
specialties together
there's some total was not 10 persons.
And so we, the World Bank decided
to support the medical education.
We initially set up the
Liberia College of Physicians,
we set up the Liberia College
of Physicians and Surgeons
because we decided the training
will follow the West African model
and any West African model,
the basic medical training
is with the university.
So that remains with the
University of Liberia,
and the residency training is,
it could be directly under
the West Africa college
or a local college, so
we established it on
under the local college and
I still West African college
to monitor so it can be linked
to the West African College model.
So we did that.
Then we built partnership with
first, we decided to recruit faculty.
And so the LCPS as the Liberian College
of Physicians and Surgeons recruited
the first set of faculty
for the first year,
there were challenges because once you go
on an individual basis
after the first year
then they put their cast on the table,
salaries they felt were low
and they started negotiating
and that was also a problem for us.
So then we decided to switch
to engage institutions instead,
so build partnership with
training institutions
universities, they
helped to recruit for us
from within their network that way
we don't have to deal with individual,
we deal with institutions and then
they can deal with the individuals.
So we did that, then
most of the institutions
that we build a partnership with
were the you where US universities.
We tried the universities
within the region
but they were not as organized as it is
with the US universities.
And some of these US
universities were also
supporting other universities
within the region.
So they already had the platform.
So we negotiated with the US
universities to recruit people
from the region since the
curriculum is from the region.
So they agree to that,
and so the recruitment
of the faculty, most of
them came from the region
except where we needed maybe
subspecialties specialties.
Sometimes they brought in faculty members
from US universities.
The beauty of that relationship,
faculty members were recruited
to come and teach in an institution
where, we didn't even have
the equipment to teach.
So the US universities position themselves
to mobilize their resources,
to help to teach also.
And a sample is,
we had one of the universities
was responsible for
to recruit faculty, to teach
surgery and to do pathology.
We did not have a pathology lab,
we brought in a pathologist
and there was no laboratory to teach.
And so (mumbles) who was responsible
for that actually worked
on mobilizing equipment
and supplies so set up the pathology lab.
And today we have the
modern pathology lab.
Now, we also do not have the capacity to
for curriculum development.
There are very few, one
or two persons in country
for the undergraduate program,
we decided we were reforming,
first, we recruited preclinical
faculty from the region
since the clinical faculty share
with the residency
training program faculty.
So the faculty from the
region are still with us
and we decided we'll reform
the medical school curriculum
reforming the curriculum, we
are not curriculum experts
but we engage the institutions,
the partner institutions to assist us
with the curriculum reform.
And they consented because
they work in institution
that have units that
look at their curriculum.
And so they work with us
and the curriculum experts,
so we formed the curriculum.
So, we divided our teams in departments,
we do all the work and weekly,
we have a Zoom meeting to
discuss the work we have done
and they give in their inputs
and that curriculum is coming on well.
Now, currently the medical
education is four years
undergraduate, and then at
five years medical training.
So you do a B.sc for us in a
biology, chemistry, or zoology.
And then you enroll
into the medical school
for another five years,
which is nine years.
Liberia happened to be the only country
in the region that has a
nine-year training program,
others are six years.
So we decided to reform the curriculum
to a seven-year curriculum.
It should be an integrated curriculum,
competency-based curriculum,
and that is been done well.
Now, in the curriculum
development process,
we know that the university
processes have to approve.
And one big concern in country is that
the sciences in from high school is weak.
We decided to do a seven-year curriculum,
so it's a one year pre-med in
the six years medical school
A one year pre-med,
three years preclinical,
three years clinical.
We know that if that curriculum goals
to the academic coordination
committee for approval.
Their first question or
their first concern will be
students coming from high school
have a deficiency in sciences.
During the war years, there
were no science teachers.
So that has been a very
big gap in the training,
it is known that's the
ministry of education
is building the sciences gradually.
So we decided to build in that process
a science camp for high school students.
So we'll do that two years before the ends
of the pre-med to make
them most successful
in passing the exams and then become
more successful in pre-med
and the medical school.
And that will help to
reduce attrition rates,
cause at the moment, the
attrition rate is high.
Sometimes, we start with 60 students
and by the end of the five
years, you have like 35.
- Okay, thank you, Dr. Dahn,
I just wanted to make sure
that I didn't step over you.
That's fascinating and it's
wonderful to hear you talk
about all this work that
we have the opportunity
to do in some ways in
partnership with you.
I wanted to pivot a little bit
because we have noticed,
of course in Liberia
there's an observable contradiction
in the status of women.
We see some women like yourself
in high positions of
authority, very strong leaders
but we also know that there's
much gender inequality
throughout the system with high levels
of gender-based violence and disparities
and education for women and girls.
Liberia's health care workforce also
has gender inequity, particularly
in the higher paying jobs
and positions of leadership.
This problem is certainly
not unique to Liberia,
we face the same challenges
here in the US and globally
but I wanted to ask about
strategies as you're thinking
about the educational pipeline,
health workforce development
what are you using to
improve gender equity
in Liberia's health systems?
- Thank you, Kristina.
It is true that women in
Liberia have held high positions
in leadership, have occupied
positions in leadership.
And it is also true that gender inequity
is also high in Liberia.
The first thing is the culture,
we grew up knowing that we
live in a male-dominated, well
male-dominated society,
women have defined roles.
And so the women themselves also think
certain jobs are for men
and it is not for them.
The previous administration
on the Madam Ellen Johnson Sirleaf
did a lot of work promoting
female leadership.
That is not the same with
the government we have to do.
There were more females
in leadership position
in the previous administration compared
to the current administration,
the previous administration the females
in the previous administration
also had more voice
in leadership compared to
the administration today.
So, how can we affect that for the future?
At the moment, we are designing programs
with some of our partners,
the program is to be able to
use policy to make decisions.
And I mean data to make policy decisions.
Normally, if you look
at the different levels
of governance in our country,
if you take the law makers for example.
Often what you will hear from them is,
decision making is numbers.
So for them the vote,
and there are very few women in there.
So their voices are not heard,
and then the way I see law makers doing
their voting too, is I'm
supporting you today because
when my time comes, you will
have to support me also.
that's the politics.
When it comes to the executive,
it's more of leadership,
how can it women provide
leadership to make policy decisions
that will affect women move positively
and promote women's leadership.
And so in our trainings moving forward
is to design trainings for
professionals for policy makers
and we'll specifically target
more women to do that training.
So we'll be able to build the skills
that they need to network, advocate
and maneuver their way in society.
So, we purposefully designing the program
to target more women and people
who are at more are disadvantaged
as compared to just leaving it open.
Sometimes you design the
program without the gender
thinking about the agenda perspective.
In the design of this program,
we look at data, we look at data from GIZ
one of the partners on
gender in the health sector.
And we realized that
all the M and E officers
in the 15 counties are males.
There were like three different positions
that they were on males.
And then I just reflected and I said
but this or that, or
no, my administration.
So then I began to think,
how did this happen?
But the design of our project did not,
did not emphasize the gender
equity and how to address them.
And so thinking loud,
maybe the M and E officers
knowing that we work in an environment
where that is very challenging,
you have to move, most of
the time they use motorbikes
to reach to places, so
maybe they recruit males
subconsciously take
that into consideration
and top on people who will
be able to ride motorbike
to reach our facilities.
But you can train women
to ride motorbikes,
so why we didn't do
that in the first place.
(laughs)
So, we were purposefully
designed our programs
to empower women to be able
to hold some of the positions
and to be able to do the kind of work
that we normally think only men can do.
- That was great, Dr. Dahn, and, I think,
one of the things I've
been pleasantly observing
in Liberia is just how
there's much freedom of speech
and people feel very
comfortable airing their views
even in the position
and to people of power.
And I hope that, we can continue
to advocacy for the rights and
status of women in Liberia.
I have another question for you,
before we try to tackle
some of the Q & A questions.
So I know that the, the
healthcare workforce program
which you helped design and implement
relies heavily on external support
both funding wise and
partners like you mentioned
but I think one thing
unique we've done in Liberia
which you somehow touched on, but we'd
like you to expand on
is how we've had support
from within the West Africa region.
So countries like Nigeria and Ghana,
and how they provided really
valuable technical support
and resources to Liberia's health systems
and medical education.
So, what are your thoughts
around advantages of this regional model,
where countries within the
region supports each other,
and also given that they share
similar limitations and lack of resources.
- Thank you.
Like I said, in my previous statements
the program was designed based
on the West African model because we live
in the region and we have to also follow
link to what is happening
within the region,
the design itself, we pay visits
so universities within the region also.
We expressed our vision to them
and they also decided they will help us.
So the advantage of
having the West African
college faculty members
to do the training for us
is that the curriculum is similar.
The work environment is similar,
and they can navigate
very difficult situations
as compared to if you bring
somebody from the West
who will have everything
at the level to them
and will not be able to wet your setting
where most things are lacking.
As compared to someone who went
to school in Ghana or Nigeria,
who did not have so much sophistication,
the situation is especially similar.
They know how to be innovative
and get things done,
and they will be able to use
the limited resources that are available
to teach the way they learn it,
and to be able to impact the knowledge
that you want to have.
And at the end of the day, it
ends up with the same results.
So that is a very big advantage,
and because we have the
West African college,
you will realize that our performance also
in the West African college exams,
for membership and
fellowship is also very good.
We've had situations
where our members went
like surgery this year, all those who went
from membership exam passed.
All those who went for final exam passed,
we've had situations where all those
who went for pediatrics passed in the past
and things like that because
the faculty members know the terrain,
they know the situation is and
so they adapt their training,
to the real practical
realities on the ground.
- Thank you, Dr. Dahn.
So we'll pivot and take
questions from the audience here.
Someone is interested in
how students are recruited
for the science camp that
you were describing earlier.
- Okay, thank you.
The students are not yet recruited,
that science camp was start 2021,
but we will be recruiting
from the 15 counties.
Initially we had engaged the AP cops
because they were in
country, in we're teaching
in the 15 we were teaching,
he did 15 counties.
And so we will work with
those who are reaching us
to identify the best science students.
We well purposefully ask
them to prioritize females
and we will recruit them
into the camp for training.
So we'll bring them to a central location
for the vacation period and
build the kind of skills
teaching them and building
the kind of skills
that are required for medical school,
critical thinking, writing
skills and those kinds of things
in addition to the sciences
that we are learning in the school.
- Thank you, Dr. Dahn.
There's actually a very
fascinating question.
I'm going to throw at
you from the audience.
We've focused on building
health systems and,
one aspect of that is that people
should have trust in the systems
that they can receive adequate care
and also trust in what health authorities,
which are very very critical,
particularly during a pandemic.
So someone's asking a naughty question
and that is what advice
would you offer the US,
regarding rebuilding
the trust of the public
after seemingly contradictory messaging
during the COVID-19 pandemic?
So this is all about,
messaging and rebuilding trust.
You know how in the US, the
loss of faith in systems,
kinda impacts people's willingness
to adhere to public health measures
take a vaccine if it's approved.
So, given your experience as the Minister
of Health of Liberia, what
advice would you offer us
about how ways to rebuild the
public trust in our systems?
- Okay, thank you.
Loss of public trust,
especially during the pandemic,
the US is not the first.
During the Ebola outbreak,
(laughs)
a similar thing happened in Liberia.
The public did not trust we had Ebola
and so they did I have
trust in the government.
People believe that the government
was making up stories to
get more donor funding,
and so they did not adhere
to the health instructions
that were coming from
the Ministry of Health,
until Ebola overwhelmed us.
The communities took upon
themselves after that
to organize themselves
to address the issues
from the community level.
So they were the ones doing the step
by step health messages.
They were the ones who
were identifying the cases
for isolation, they were the ones
who were mobilizing resources
to support family members
and communities who family
members got affected.
That model is what we took,
we revised our community health strategy
and policy and that is what
we are implementing now.
Now, what I've realized with
the outbreak of COVID-19,
they like your scenario
and the US scenario,
my own perspective is the not using data
for decision making.
The technicians are
there, the US government
and that's the interesting thing
about it was the key partner who helped us
to establish the incident
management system,
the emergency operation centers,
the surveillance systems
that we have in place today.
that is addressing the COVID issues.
What I see with the US,
those systems are there
they are routine healthcare
systems are there.
The emergency systems are also there.
The difference I see here is they have
also decentralized our system.
And so today the county help
teams respond to emergencies,
they start responding to emergencies
before the national public
health institute goes to assist.
And I think that is the difference,
with the CDC sending
teams to states to help.
Another thing I see is the politics,
the politics, the government,
and this happens with the government.
It is so sad to say that politicians
will use the population to remain
in power or to gain popularity.
The technicians are giving
information and giving guidance
but politicians want
to hold onto positions
want to be seen as working,
and so they'll leave audit data aside
and they follow the politics as a result,
things are not working as
it should work in the US,
that's my own analysis that
also happens here in Liberia sometimes.
The politicians will take things,
we have had hospitals that
were built in the past,
because a politician wanted
a hospital in their village.
There's a hospital (mumbles)
that one patient have never entered,
a very big structure only because
a politician wanted recognition.
The politicians have to listen,
to the technicians, they
have to work together
in the interests of the population
and not for themselves, thank you.
- Thank you so much, Dr.
Dahn, it's very powerful.
So we have just a few more minutes,
wanted to ask you, we
have many individuals
including students in the
US, in Liberia, all over,
who are passionate about the issues
that we've been discussing today
and who want to engage in this kind
of work after they graduate.
And I wanted to ask what
would be your advice for them,
competencies and skills
you think they need,
or how you would advise them
if they go forward in their careers.
- Thank you.
My own scenario, I was a
mid-level professional,
so I graduated from medical school.
I worked in the hospital for some time,
and at a certain time, I
went over to the ministry
as a director without leadership skills
or management skills and I
still did the clinical work
alongside with the Ministry
of Public Health work
until I went for my training,
for my MBAs at a University of Washington,
that training had a component
that focused on leadership and management.
In addition to, even though
leadership and management
was built in all the topics
even in the church, I had that.
But there were specific sessions
on leadership and management.
And because I had practical experience
prior to going to school,
it helped me to map out
what my shortcomings were.
So it reshaped the way our
work and the way I think,
it helped me to develop advocacy skills.
It helped me to learn how to network
among partners, my supervisors,
leaders to get things done.
So even if, say for
instance, if I have a boss
and I have an addition that my boss
is finding difficult to I can actually get
to another person who I
think my boss would listen to
and that person can help to
position my vision for me
Communication skill is key,
you must be able to
articulate your vision.
You must be able to think strategically
and must be able to think ahead.
That's where you are
able to position things.
You are able to navigate the system
to be able to get things done.
You must be able to know
who are your stakeholders,
you should know who can
help you to be successful
and who can help to break you
and how you can bring them together.
You must be innovative,
you must be thinking
ahead, ahead of the work.
So those are some of the
things that actually helped me
and I actually learned that
after some years of practice
went back to school I was
able to clearly define
what I was doing previously
and what I think I could do
moving forward, thank you.
- Thank you, Dr. Dahn, I think
it's always just inspiring
to see how you've
climbed through the ranks
and really left a footprints
at all different levels
of the health system.
So I just have one quick question,
we have just six minutes before we close.
So before I hand off to Kristina
to give a closing statement
I couldn't resist asking
you one last question.
So, have current challenges
including COVID-19
and you've got, showed leadership
during the time of Ebola for your country.
And so I would just like you to
in the next two, three minutes, just,
share with us your thoughts as to
what you think are the next big challenges
for global health in the
next five to 10 years.
So, both within the Liberian context
and maybe US context, we see, for example
for an infectious disease,
like COVID-19 how,
our destinies are tied globally.
And, that we really have to work together
to confront of our biggest challenges.
So, what do you see in
the next five to 10 years
as being, future global health challenges?
- Well, pandemics will always be with us,
just how we are trying
to solve the problems
with disease outbreak is the same way
that pathogens are strategizing
to challenge us with new outbreaks.
And so, as we design systems
we should remember that we
need to design the systems.
Yes, emergency respond to it
but think long term,
because you will always
have an outbreak that
you have to respond to.
At least in my lifetime,
I've seen HIV, Bad Flu,
(indistinct) disease,
COVID 19, Ebola, I've heard some,
I've seen some, so it's like
we'll continue to have our outbreaks.
And so building the
systems is key to managing
both the routine services
and the outbreaks.
So there's a need for us to not to give up
on building a system once
that things come back,
return to normal, we forget
and then we go back to
our regular routine.
We should always have the systems
to be able to provide
routine healthcare services
and be able to respond to emergency
when there's an outbreak.
Another challenge is the it's
non-communicable diseases
that is also growing gradually,
somehow in the developed world.
It has been there for some time,
but in the developing
world, it is growing.
And for us in the developing world
to manage these things is expensive,
so we need to think on
preventives seriously.
So those are the two key things
that I think we should look
into moving into the future.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Dr. Dahn.
For that answer for this
fantastic conversation today,
for taking time out of your
very busy schedule to join us,
it's such an honor to have you
as one of our conversation
series speakers.
I also want to thank you Onyema
for co-moderating with me.
It's wonderful to be doing this together,
thank you so much.
And I would like to thank the
audience for your engagement
and your insightful questions.
It's just been wonderful to
have everybody together today,
thank you so much.
And with these remarks,
we are concluding our 2020
Yale Institute for Global
Health Conversation series,
thank you all again for joining us today
and wish you a safe and
joyful holiday season
and a happy new year, thank you so much.
- Thank you, and thanks to all of you.
I hope I was able to
meet your expectations.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you Dr. Dahn.
- Bye bye, everybody.